coming up on the season finale of MILF
Island hot mamas but who will be the
final mommy you'd like to eat oh you
know I came here to be number one coming
up next here on NBC
you guys gonna do any work today or zip
it MILF island is on
20 mils 58th grade boys no rules and
tonight One winner
this show is the worst didn't one of
those MILFs die during production she
had too much champagne and a monkey
Nocturne and some quicksand it could
happen anywhere
foreign
remember this
Deborah and Shauna squaring off an
erection curve
um I don't I don't really watch this
show
right before she was from MILF Island
she was just a struggling actress living
in La wow that's inspiring she has real
star quality you should meet with her
wait is that why you called me up here
sir I have Sumner Redstone calling to
congratulate you I'll return the coals
have been pouring in all night no
filing's huge I guess we should be out
celebrating
saluta
you've kept it tight
Heidi
we no longer want to hit that
get off MILF Island
[Music]
I mean my implants exploded and I didn't
even ask to get off the Catapult now
boys
two meals left
Deborah
and Deborah
but one of them is going home and it
will be revealed
after three more breaks I was here
folding MILF Island t-shirts until two
in the morning and then you didn't even
offer me one needless to say I grumbled
about you to anyone who would listen
I don't know what to say again
yourself and the show
you may have compromised my chances of
running this company and needless to say
you've heard me personally
lemon do you have anything you want to
add
you disgust me
[Music]
oh that's over tomorrow
she played the game so well she
manipulated she lied she got a pretty
bad staph infection but tonight Deborah
is our win Jack I was vacationing with
my family in Europe in a country only
rich people know about it's been Borgia
no better but I can't tell you anyway my
mother called to tell me that I'm going
to be on Law and Order and ER so I
called my agent to find out when did I
shoot these things that's the beauty of
this Cherry it's all done with computers
when you see it you're going to love it
25 sexy moms 50 sweaty 8th grade boys
and one beloved American Comedy star
this Wednesday on MILF Island really is
that really your pitch okay
this is a two-way street
all right Jerry what NBC shows do you
want to be digitally inserted into I
like lost it's not you guys
Jerry don't be difficult the fact of the
matter is that Seinfeld vision is
perfectly legal and there's nothing you
can do to stop us I'm sorry
but
it's business here's some business how
about I buy NBC and turn it into the
biggest Lane Bryant in Midtown
[Laughter]
by NBC like you've got four million
dollars just laying around
Jerry I'm sorry give me two days
and I'll come up with something you'll
really be proud of besides you owe me
remember Saint Bart's I saved your life
from that shark all right jack
I'll come back
but I still think you shot a dolphin